ladies and gentlemen we are here in
nashville tennessee
we are at the daily wires headquarters
and uh we got a special show tonight
there's a lot to talk about of course dc
is experiencing busloads of illegal
immigrants being sent by the governor of
texas we've got some interesting
conversations around around these
schools and the education issue once
again has become something
well it's persistent in the news and
we're going to talk about that we've got
a couple really great guests
in about 15 minutes
the daily wire ben shapiro andrew klavan
michael knowles matt walsh jeremy boring
i hope i named everybody everybody are
going to be taking over
our feed actually taking over and tim
cast ira will flip into the daily wire
and i'm going to run out of the trailer
in tornado weather yeah no joke and try
and make it into their studio and we are
all going to hang out and have a
conversation that'll last for just about
15 minutes then we're going to come back
and hang out with our awesome guests and
keep our show going so i saw those
people chatting saying there's no way
benjamin the daily wire crew are taking
over yes they literally are they've got
special camera rigs set up to just take
over it's going to be a blast oh yeah i
hope it works but uh it's been really
fun hanging out with the guys here in in
nashville the crew they're awesome i
just uh got to play some video games
with them and absolutely destroyed the
entire uh crew of the daily wire because
they're not gonna play video games so uh
let's just get to it joining us today we
got we got a couple really awesome
guests we got jason whitlock
from the blaze uh tv fearless with jason
whitlock good to be back has it it's
probably been a year yeah i think so i
was on the show
uh
you know i'm still fat but a little less
a little less so although no one said
anything i was hoping that tim or lydia
or somebody would say hey man i think he
lost 10 pounds well i was thinking it
yeah
i lost him way too you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i cut out the sugars in uh like around
october november mm-hmm it's worked it's
worked out pretty well you're still
wearing the hat though so that kind of
threw me off good
i couldn't see that
that's the constant yeah we got colin
wright
evolutionary biologists run the website
reality's last stand to talk a lot about
sex and gender debunking a lot of the
pseudoscience about
biological sex and the notion that it's
a
social construct or a spectrum
it's good to be here thank you thanks
for coming out we got ian what's up
everybody i was actually sitting in the
daily wire production headquarters
eyeballing the way they run and man that
is a cool operation great group of
people in there and they're a well-oiled
machine isn't it so different from us
yeah we've got like we've got like duct
tape and beanies
and they've got this massive production
rig there's like 50 people running
around i'm like i don't know i don't
know what any people are truly epic like
lydia presses buttons that's right
yeah i'm here in the corner pushing
buttons this time i got ian's camera
right which has been a struggle for me
you guys may have noticed i've tried i
kept i don't know what i have against
ian's camera but it's not because i hate
ian i'm just struggling over here in the
corner camera the wrong ones i know i
can't get it can i say this i think i
like this rv it's great better than
going to your compound oh yeah which i
had trouble finding and i remember i
think i had to order mcdonald's because
you guys fed me hot pockets who gave you
hot pots
i don't know no what i don't remember
whatever i refuse i reject these
allegations it's very homeless
i know i do love it you know the idea is
maybe once a month bring the trailer out
to a different location and we're
actually we want to do friday night live
events so we would do irl at a venue
on stage
we got to hire the people to get to that
point who can come out on a wednesday
set the whole thing up early on the
friday and then we would do the show in
the trailer but then friday night sell
tickets people can come out hang out in
the audience and actually watch the show
i think that'd be really cool be awesome
that sounds awesome all right well let's
let's try and squeeze in some talk
before the daily wire ends up taking
this show over before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
to help support our work we're going to
have an amazing members only segment
coming up tonight at 11 p.m eastern as a
member you'll get access to the entire
library of our members only content and
you will also be supporting our
journalists but more importantly head
over to youtube.com
pop culture crisis and subscribe
to our mostly apolitical culture show
this is why if you're into it if you
like talk about celebrities movies video
games gossip and all that stuff we can't
just complain about cultural changes we
can't just complain about political
issues politics is downstream from
culture we have to engage in these
cultural issues if if we're if we care
about it and we have to make culture so
not only are we working on shows like
tales from the inverted world which is a
seasonal mystery paranormal
investigative podcast we're also
engaging with talking about celebrities
and movies and games too and that's what
the crew over at pop culture crisis does
every day so subscribe there if you want
to hear more about that stuff and you'll
know that when we talk about what's
going on with the latest movie or disney
it's going to be coming from a place of
our values personal responsibility
liberty etc let's let's let's talk about
this first story
uh it's a crazy story but i don't want
to i don't want to go hard on deep
cultural issues because we're going to
we're going to lose control of the feed
in about 10 minutes
so this from timcast.com
first texas bus
drops off illegal immigrants in
washington d.c the convoy is part of
texas governor greg abbott's push to
secure the southern border and stem the
flow of illegal immigration from central
america so basically what happens is joe
biden's administration starts sending
illegal immigrants to communities in
texas people get really upset by this
for obvious reasons he's been doing it
all over the country even in the dead of
night the governor of texas said okay
i'll tell you what you want to do that
here i'm going to send these people
to dc
gen saki calls it a publicity stunt
then he actually does it ron desantis
says he's going to do the same thing but
send him up to delaware boom that was
going to be that's where they need to
send him exactly
it's not perfect right sending sending
people to delaware will just make people
in delaware upset but the point is like
hey biden's the one who's doing it so
why don't you guys get a taste here's
the thing i i'd be willing to believe
that biden's already sending illegal
immigrants to delaware and other states
they're all over the country so
well uh
i don't know if you guys have thoughts
on this because i'm curious of the
process do they do they just take them
on a bus and
pull up to a street and they just tell
them to scatter what
were they getting dropped off at my
understanding is they actually just
walked them off the bus and said have a
nice day whoa
yup that's wild yeah the people have all
uh agreed to go on the bus i believe too
this is only people that have acquiesced
they have agreed to go on the bus
so i wonder if that'll end up being an
endless supply of people
or will they run out of because it can't
just be a one-off because it is you know
ginsake if this is just a one-off
publicity stunt you get headlines but if
there's a steady stream of them being
dropped off in delaware in washington dc
you can keep that drum beat going and
people start experiencing what you know
has happened to
uh these states that are on the mexican
border uh if you can start really
feeling that experience in dc and in
delaware and other places the poli
biting these guys are gonna have to
react
what's our immigration deal just
is the most bizarre it's not the most
bizarre because we have so many bizarre
things going on but one of these are the
top two we'll get to them all i'm sure
what is the delaware what's so hot about
being delaware being a destination
that's joe biden's state okay yeah
heading to his home
his home state i see it getting
i you know
there's a there's an article from the
daily beast where they said it's
xenophobic
for for the republicans to do this what
and i'm just like hold on joe biden is
sending these people by force
on buses to texas
greg abbott is asking them if they want
to get a bus to go to dc
so is is not what joe biden doing
xenophobic it's this is the game we've
been talking about a lot but it just it
happens the double standard it's it's an
endless conversation every day about the
double standard between what the the
administration the democrats the
establishment are allowed to do always
defended and anybody who counters in any
way is accused of all the worst
far-right whatever
i think
they would perhaps prefer to be in dc as
well to be easier to get your free cell
phones right there in dc there's
probably a direct connect they probably
got a deal set up with cricket or
somebody to get these people the free uh
cell phones they were promised i don't i
don't think it's fair to call him
xenophobe xenophobic personally i just
looked up the definition one unduly
fearful of what is foreign and
especially of people or foreign origin
so being unduly fearful of what is
foreign it's not that's i think a lot of
this isn't coming from fear of foreigner
it's that you disrupt the local economy
when you import people that don't
understand the culture or speak the
language and you got to be really
careful about disrupting your your
economy the united states is very young
it hasn't experienced a large
immigration that completely altered the
government like when people come in
slowly and then all of a sudden they're
the ones that start to get there they
happen to the roman empire i mean it's
the way the roman empire fell really is
the peop the barbarians from the north
or whatever they came in over hundreds
years and then now they're the
government and then yeah i don't know if
i believe in hyper xenophobia but i am
probably xenophobic because
i want people that share my values
in this country i want people that
believe in freedom as the ultimate prize
not entitlement as the ultimate prize or
victimization as the ultimate prize and
again i don't know the people flooding
our our borders and immigrating
illegally maybe they do believe in
american freedom maybe that's why
they're they're coming here but i don't
think that's what the democrats and the
people leading our uh immigration policy
i don't think those are the values they
want them to have
uh i don't think you're xenophobic you
know they use these phobia words to make
you sound unreasonable and if you're
just saying
i'm not look i'm personally i'm not
scared of people from central south
america or you even have people from
africa coming in i'm not scared of
any of these people in fact i know some
some people and they're they're good
people i hear you know trump said some
of them are good people right now the
reality is they want what a lot of
people want opportunity in america in
fact i have more respect for them and
their desires than i do for many of
these woke people in this country
there's one thing i am worried about is
the woke people but the issue of
xenophobia is that that's a ridiculous
term it's meant to obfuscate the real
conversation the real conversation is
there are economic limits to what you
can do with with people just coming
across whenever they want you end up
strangling the labor market you end up
flooding the labor market supply and
demand takes effect and then people's
wages get depressed there's challenges
there and then as you pointed out there
are a lot of people here who want to be
here and again i do respect that desire
to be in america because i know how much
this country rocks
but it they don't if they don't
understand our constitution if they
don't understand our values then it
dilutes our values and the things that
made this country great so if there's
somebody who says guys here's the the
recipe for a great cake and then you say
we're going to let 10 more bakers in who
don't know how to bake it but they're
going to be involved well then things
are going to get a little wishy-washy
that's why my attitude is always like
let everybody come everybody can can
come but they gotta wait in line like
normal and go through a standard process
that way we can make sure the recipe
doesn't get disrupted but we can have
more cooks in the kitchen just as long
as everybody's following the rules and
we all agree on how it's supposed to go
it's not fear it's actually
it's i would consider it to be more
compassionate so that you can make sure
people can thrive and that you're not
just throwing them into the middle of a
desert where these kids are are dying
dehydration i think it you're talking
about just being responsible
and it's no different than who you would
allow into your home if you got kids
wife husband whatever
uh you want to be a responsible
homeowner and so you just don't let any
and everybody into your home
that's the way i feel about america you
see these stories of the the refugee
crisis
and a lot of people are like you know
are you going to let
some of these refugees into your houses
many of these these left activists who
were very much like yeah we got to let
all the refugees in would not offer up
any of their homes now i do personally
know left-wing woke activists who did
and it was great success and i'm like
that's amazing that you had the
resources you had a plan
you were you were capable to do this not
everybody is
asking a middle-class family who's just
scraping by paycheck to paycheck to open
their doors to somebody that's what
you're doing when you're like let's have
open borders let's let's let's allow all
these people to come in yeah i get it
you guys might be in big cities with a
higher cost of standard of living a
higher cost of living you have more
money but the poor working class people
who are paycheck to paycheck it's
straining their lives and that's that's
that's that's not that's not okay right
you gotta be you gotta you gotta respect
the working class people
it's that whole concept of like the
the luxury belief where you can have
these beliefs because you're not really
incurring the cost directly you're sort
of exporting those costs to those around
you who are taking the brunt of the
policies you advocate for like the
people who are most likely to say
something like you know abolish the
police
they tend to be like upper class white
people who have probably live in gated
communities these aren't the people who
are dealing in these these cities these
areas where there's high crime so it's
really easy for someone like that to say
you know these these platitudes that
really sound good they sort of give them
this credit to the people around them um
because again they're not incurring
these costs the guy named rob henderson
he coined that term let me oh i want to
add two just to back to the conversation
about the buses
bringing illegal immigrants into these
areas
just does exactly what democrats were
hoping was going to happen anyway that
you're going to increase the population
of a district which results in a larger
in the census resulting in a larger
population after the census and then
they'll get more congressional seats
more electoral seats so yeah send them
to dc send them you know dc maybe make
sense because they don't get
representation
sending sending people to delaware just
gives delaware more congressional power
and more electoral votes so the real
issue is you know people should be
welcome to this country with open arms
through a legal process that makes sure
they thrive and so do we
but i think i think the main issue is
people on the left they're not having
kids so they need to find ways that in
the next 20 years they will still have
voting power and that's by bringing in
new people who have a tendency to vote
for democratic policies and democratic
politicians
conservatives have kids liberals don't
so liberals need to go to the schools to
get your kids in line with their views
so they can conservative kids on their
side or they need to bring people in who
will side with them
reminds me of a netflix documentary that
i'll watch called wild wild country
it's about portland
or
area in oregon not portland but an area
in oregon that was taken over by
this indian hindu
uh
like no shot nosha
uh
he was basically a sex guru or whatever
and they started literally to gain
voting power and to take over this
section of of oregon they started
recruiting this happened in the 70s this
is like a real life story they started
bussing in people from los angeles
homeless people into this area so they
could change the voting demographics
in oregon so they could take over more
and and it ended up the homeless people
were on drugs and so many of them
violent and they actually turned on the
people that brought them there because
their needs weren't getting met
uh it's it's one of the best
greatest documentaries i've ever seen
because it happened in the 70s and
explains everything that's going on
today it takes time
and they're willing to invest the time
so if someone who is eight years old
today gets indoctrinated in a school
they're voting in 10 years
so it's it's a long game we can't think
in in short term cycles like two and
four years you got to think ahead you
got to think 10 20 years someone born
today
more likely to be conservative because
of just standard demographics of
conservatives having kids liberals not
and also having abortions so you got 18
years until conservatives get that
advantage how do you counter that they
know this
they play the long game conservatives i
think you know uh
the the the the politically minded
politically uh
careered
are probably thinking about this on the
conservative side i think regular people
miss this you know they don't understand
necessarily why the schools do what they
do when they go after kids
a lot of what the left is doing seems
desperate to me
and it makes me think that they think
they only have a limited amount of time
to execute their plan
before
the whole thing collapses in on them
yeah i was thinking how much of it is
desperation how much of it is instinct
like
seems like humans have an instinct to
parent i don't know i do i don't know if
you guys do i feel like i just love kids
i wanted to help kids uh and and so i
was like well if i never actually have
kids what's reproduction if i make a
bunch of videos and there's a bunch of
copies of it that i'm forming some sort
of reproduction that will affect society
and maybe i could help the children that
way very leftist mentality you know it's
very much like what we see now and i
wonder if it's just like they really
want to help but and then they're but
they're so twisted that they're trying
to help by you know infusing these
specific ideals
or if they actually want to hurt people
i i'm not getting the vibe that they
want to hurt people uh it just seems
more like a communist uh they want power
mental shift that's like taking hold of
these people or something they don't
know communist is the right word they
want power and they're not afraid to
they're not they're not afraid to
inflict collateral damage on people to
get it
i think that's true of anyone you know
but i think there's a tendency what we
see with the establishment the
democratic party and even the uniparty
republican types what's happened is
there's been a populist uprising also on
the left i think a lot of the bernie
people many of them moved over nine
million obama voters moved over to voted
for trump it's really just about
populism
we we had steve bannon saying he was far
right and then he says tax the rich and
i'm like i don't know that's far right
dude i think that's actually a left
position but it's just a populist
position it's about are you in support
of elites telling you what to do and how
to live or do you think the people we
the people should decide and and form
our own government
we the people were gonna say jason i
well i was gonna piggyback uh ian am i
right are you an atheist or agnostic
more agnostic than anything okay and so
what i see from the left honestly is
just
they think that
they're secular so they think they're
god
and
uh it's just a power grab and and again
did you probably watch the or saw a
little bit of like game of thrones and
game of thrones is just this story when
it was good the first four or five
seasons about what human beings will do
for power in anything they'll do
anything for power and that and
particularly if you don't have some kind
of religious belief some kind of faith
and a higher power and you think
you're capable of being the ultimate
decider
it puts you in a very bad you'll do very
bad things for power because you have so
much belief in your ability to control
things and do what's best for other
people
and i just don't have that kind of
arrogance because
i believe i'm just a very tiny
insignificant part of this thing that
god put together
and
you know i don't want that kind of power
i literally want to stick to the
principles taught in the bible
and and you know
hope for the best and hope that i'm
right
uh
and i i just see
the the left is so secular
and and they see themselves as god
that's what scares us what makes me
nervous about the churches i feel like
the the church has acted as now they are
the mouthpiece of god it's like another
form of of secularism almost like who
cares about a building and a guy that
tells you he's a priest like god's real
god's out there god is an energy field
flowing like it's it's there it's always
there
you don't need someone to to you don't
need to like be told you don't need
authority to tell you that what about
your relationship with god i feel the
church out of it i feel it i i science
has helped me see the cosmic microwave
background radiation for instance is
this web of energy left over after the
big bang you see arcing through star
systems and then you feel your heart
beating it's getting like
the heat is coming from without like
it's we're getting these electrical
currents pumping through us and after i
started to see i
smoke a lot of weed that helped a lot
and to feel the heat and then you can
feel your own heat and i'm like wow did
jesus do reiki and then you see that
jesus like went off maybe to india for
some period in his early life and and
studied like
hinduism and reiki and came back as like
a healer so i started doing reiki and
that's real let me let me throw in there
i think i actually enjoy when when ian
and sheamus talk about religious stuff
because he uh sheamus comes from a more
like um
what's the right word uh he he's he's
devout you know he goes to mass ian has
a bunch of ideas about spirituality that
i think need to be answered and and it
creates something interesting i think i
certainly think ian sees or feels
something that
you know needs to be answered or defined
and maybe maybe there's a
in the more rigid structures
people have thought about these things i
also want to add the suspense is killing
me because i'm like what's going on i
know yeah yeah yeah someone's supposed
to come to the door yeah it should be
any second 7 20. i know i'll say briefly
you know as a card-carrying atheist
myself
um
a major problem is we have you know it's
not religion per se that's the problem i
think it's like the dogma that tends to
go hand-in-hand with it and a lot of
people on the left a lot of these woke
people they've convinced themselves that
they're not religious and that they also
have no dogma
where that's the complete error like
they have their own dogma but since
they've convinced themselves they're
non-religious they think they're
impervious to this they don't see
themselves as actually acting religious
in many areas where they absolutely are
we're going to go um
all right we're good to go everybody so
we're doing something weird all right
here we go this is the first on tim cast
irl they're taking over they're taken to
they're taking are we still on the air
are they already taking they're gonna
steal us in just one second you heard it
here you guys
oh we're still on the air oh snap let me
show you guys what's going on um i think
we're off now we've given them the
stream oh yes we have i gave them
control yeah
um
um
so
um
that tim has been broadcasting from our
hill all week from uh from a fifth-wheel
trailer that he converted into a mobile
studio and tonight he's gonna learn how
god feels about it because we have
thunderstorms coming through nashville
in 45 minutes and he'll still be
broadcasting all right
the most dangerous place in america to
be welcome really show everybody
thanks for having me absolutely this is
the best lunch
head on tim keste
i really like being on your
good
um
foreign
foreign
um
foreign
um
foreign
it's
so
thank you
something that affects about michelle
obama and uh i don't want to put words
in joe's mouth but he mentioned
something about barack obama being a
great president or something to that
effect and michelle obama being a
potentially great option i think i think
you know he's relevant for one having
the biggest podcast in the world but i
think he speaks to a lot of people who
are in the middle and confused or don't
necessarily know how they're gonna uh
vote come 2020 uh 2022 and 2024
but i think if these people
the moderates independence former left
people see michelle obama i think a lot
of them will be convinced
to vote democrat again i'm not entirely
convinced for me my brain exploded after
2020 with just yeah i'm done with this
you know i'm uh or 20 2018 even when i
think it was 31 seats that did
districts that voted for trump
vote democrat and all of these moderate
democrats said we're going to bring you
kitchen table issues we're not going to
focus on culture war issues and the
first thing they do is they move to
impeach trump and it felt like i was
just spit on i was like you know i had
faith that if i if i just you know push
back i donated to a lot some of these
democrats thinking that they'll actually
re you know reconfigure things and fix
this and they only made it worse the
only the only thing i think that that
could really harm michelle obama if
short run is i think that she really has
ideologically she always has been very
radical and i think that she will
re-embrace wokeness because she too is
in that bubble i think the most
ironically the thing that we complain
the most about is probably the thing
that may save the republic and that is
the media bias the media bias is so
strong that democrats do not understand
that there's an entire world outside of
the beltway that just thinks they're
crazy and so the reason that you see the
white house saying things like well you
know it's very important that we use the
doj to crack down on people stopping
little girls from being turned into
little boys the reason they say that is
because the new york times agrees with
them in the washington post agrees with
them and everybody they know agrees with
them the other thing about michelle
obama is that she's attractive to people
i guess not to me but the people as like
an idea
but if she's running for office then
she's actually got to be out there
talking when you listen to her talk kind
of to your point about how radical [ __ ]
but also she's just really a kind of a
vile human being i'll never forget this
story she told on a podcast somewhere
about when she experienced
racism like she was still harboring this
resentment because she went to get ice
cream and a white woman
didn't notice her and like and cut in
front of her and she told this whole
story about how she was a victim of
racism as the first lady united states
uh because a white woman was getting ice
cream before herself so there's that
story that she told about her she went
to the grocery store and she was tall so
somebody asked her to take something
down from the top exactly that she said
that that was racism it's like no you're
just tall i mean i i'd ask matt to get
something from the top shelf for me
who who are the voters who fall for that
stuff
i agree with you tim you know i think
that she's i think michelle obama i
don't think she would run but i think
that she is a good candidate if she runs
but you know the voters are not as uh
enamored of identity politics as the
democrats are they're in no way are they
well the the the poll about the parental
rights and education bill in florida has
overwhelming support from democrat
voters right who were polled at the very
least yet they doubled down on this
stuff it's like you were saying that the
media bias is palpable i don't know if
you guys saw cnn plus only has 10 000
daily active users
wow you know
hold on just a second yeah
but i think i enjoy chris
wallace's new show what have i done i
think
by the way who who was the business
genius at warner who's like okay so we
have cnn and no one watch
what if we take the same post and we put
them behind a paywall
doing more boring things
i mean how does this go wrong here guys
well this seems like a genius business
plan to me
i will tell you guys something
interesting though because uh matt and i
were talking about this the other day
when i asked you why is it the daily
wires 600 000 plus subscribers cnn can't
even get 10 000 daily users you
mentioned mission i think is what you
said right
when i worked i said in me i said the
reason is me and then
the number two reason he did say that he
said he was better than everybody uh
you know in in uh when i was working for
these big corporate media outlets i was
at a company called fusion which is abc
news and univision
they said mission driven storytelling
that was that was their line as to what
their goals were it's almost like they
were either predicting or wanting
politics to be the main driver of what
was going to bring people to different
media outlets the only issue is i felt
like their narratives were built on lies
and manipulation we have to withhold
information from people trick them
feed them only the information we want
whereas i feel like with what you guys
do with what we do it's here's
everything let's argue about it yep well
that's that's what i love about this
show that we get to do once a month is
that we quite often disagree and those
disagreements i think are central to to
what makes the daily wire work i think
at the core of the daily wire success is
our fundamental religious difference
that we talked about it today in fact
that our fundamental religious
disagreement
means that central to our friendship is
the idea that there's not ubiquity and
that there's not
unanimity in our thought and that's it's
not that we don't have a strong
perspective as a company it's not that
we don't have a strong uh that we don't
have a side in the fight
but it's that we that we are actually
engaged in the exchange of ideas and
trying to always learn more and and know
more and be better tim thank you for uh
well for coming on uninvited please feel
free to invite yourself on the show
again in the future
thank you to all of our daily wired.com
members for making this possible we're
going to wrap up because there's a
thunderstorm rolling in this guy's got
to get back to his tornado bait trailer
and ben shapiro has to get on an
airplane and get out of here head over
to dailywire.com subscribe use promo
code build the future you still have 23
hours left to become a member at 45
off we'd really appreciate you being a
member we appreciate our members making
it possible for us to do the work that
we're doing including fighting woke
disney so thanks again we'll see you
next week we'll give you a fake laugh i
don't know one of these days
should i just run out the door now yeah
you should leave
thanks guys
odd here you may have had a uh technical
glitch there in the earlier show earlier
part of the show they were talking about
uh trump desantis and who was gonna run
and then they got they kind of parlayed
the conversation into the democrats and
who they thought was gonna run for
democrats i thought that ben shapiro
made a very interesting point about uh
populism when he mentioned michelle
obama and running a populist candidate
i'm interested to see what you guys
think about that
the michelle obama
questioned that part of the discussion
is what fascinated me because
i i i do think she would probably be the
best candidate for the democrats i do
think
again
corporate media is obsessed with oh
so-and-so's making history because
they're the first
black woman this just like we just saw
with kidanji brown jackson
and so
people love they're fascinated by
participating or witnessing history and
it's like and again it's like when
barack obama first ran in 2008 i think a
lot of people voted because this is a
history making deal and i want to be on
the record and i voted for barack obama
and it's proof that i'm not racist it's
got the history building and they've
they've spent a lot of years curating
michelle obama's image
and having the last name obama is just
going to be huge in in the realm of
politics so yeah she she is the nuclear
option for sure we parlayed what you
guys were talking about with populism
and i liked how ben brought up michelle
obama i think we may have had an audio
technical glitch in the first part and
then we it seemed to smooth that worked
yeah you guys got it the first time you
know and it's all about it when you have
a new piece of technology a new cool
idea you try it and if it fails you try
it again and you do it and then you get
it right and that's what we're doing
they look great through the rain yeah
you're kind of damp now
and uh hang out those guys cigar smoke
everywhere oh gosh
uh what were you guys talking about so
let's uh let's let's let's get back and
thanks for you know sitting around while
i was doing that thing
i enjoyed watching that was fascinating
yeah that was not the conversation i was
expecting but i was fascinated you know
shout out to ron desantis thanks for
bringing them up and we were just
basically carrying the conversation
forward from where you guys were talking
about you know who do you think the
democrats who do you think the democrats
are going to run because i cannot
imagine it would be joe biden at this
point i will say with uh
you know i'm sitting there and i know
i'm in for the last few minutes of the
daily wires show and but i don't want to
just keep talking over everybody but i
also kind of felt like well i should
talk because i'm only here for a few
minutes yeah but i don't i don't i you
know i know ben was saying he thinks
they have to have joe biden run
they're going to strap him to a gurney
and wheel him out i think he's right
but i don't think even strapping him to
a gurney would make it possible for him
to run the dude couldn't
couldn't run in the first place he was
calling a lid and just sleeping the
whole time yeah and uh and and ben
mentioned it was a referendum on trump i
don't even think we're gonna have a
referendum on biden i think we're having
a referendum on democrats so this this
midterm election is gonna be big
and i think
it's gonna there's a lot of variables
between now and 2022 there's no the
midterm elections and 2024
but
i don't you know
it's tough to say because i feel like
reading the news every day watching
what's going on seeing the impacts
that certainly regular people must be
feeling some of this
but maybe that's just wrong maybe even
though we might see the problem and have
some some uh solutions to offer regular
people don't know what the problem is so
they're being approached by two
different groups democrats and
republicans who are saying trust me i'll
i'll do right by you
i'm sitting here saying i've watched the
news relentlessly i've been reading
about this i've seen the policies i
don't think every anybody's perfect i
think everybody gets a little bit of the
blame but obviously donald trump was
better and they say oh but you're biased
i can't trust you and it's like
you know they call you right wing if
you're telling the truth at this point
if you say something like
joe biden flew his son on air force two
to china for a private equity deal
that's a conflict of interest they say
that's a right-wing talking point no
it's a fact and i'm not gonna vote for a
guy who did that donald trump also has
you know stupid bs for sure they were
advertising trump golf resorts or
whatever on some state department
website i'm not a fan of that
but if i have to choose between the two
trump is objectively better
well we got a tornado hopefully yeah
i i think this is going to be an
election where there's a lot of people
when i put myself in that camp
sort of those disaffected left of center
people who are still consider themselves
liberals in any sense during the last
election like i couldn't bring myself to
vote for either of the parties
i didn't like trump i just i couldn't
just bring myself to vote for him i
couldn't vote for for biden either but
if this next election doesn't have trump
in it
i mean it's just there's so many people
i think that are in my in my boat
who there's no reason not to vote for a
republican anymore desantis has all the
best parts of trump where he's you know
he's bold he's anti-woke he's gonna go
after people he's not gonna take crap
from anybody but he doesn't have like
that
narcissistic insanity what's he gonna do
next is he just gonna you know start
pushing the nuke button or something and
i think that's actually a powerful thing
i think we're this is the first election
in a while where those disaffected
liberals are actually free to vote their
mind
in a way they hadn't been previously
let's talk about these stories that we
pulled up
we got uh one from the new york post
mind the tornado above us i apologize
from the new york post
espn star jason whitlock blasts disney
for feminizing sports
i yes and i think this is gonna this is
gonna be uh this will play a role
in the upcoming elections in that
you've got what's happening with the
ncaa swimming with uh with leah thomas
and i know i've been critical of people
who refuse to speak up saying if you're
not speaking up publicly how can i
defend you because people will just say
nobody's mad about this what are you
complaining about if you can't stand up
for yourself but i will say at the very
least these people will be secret trump
voters like we saw in 2016 and 2020 a
large percentage of people who would not
admit it but once they get into the
polling booth they look around look over
their shoulders and then hit trump a
million times
things like that voting it's it's secret
for a reason because that's a natural
part of people's minds when they see
crap out there they don't want to have
to stand up and say it but they're going
to vote the way they feel
see the lights flicker there
how did the lights flicker we're on
independent electricity magnetic fields
well so so jason let's talk about this
uh your take on the feminization of
sports well
i think a lot of people it kind of went
over their heads in 1996 when
disney acquired abc
and espn
and and that
once you start
once you're taken over by disney you now
disney's going to promote its values
there's no
greater
cultural force
than perhaps disney across the entire
globe
and
so i think disney came in with an agenda
i think in 1994 disney tried to acquire
nbc couldn't
nbc at that time had the nba broadcast
disney has wanted to get into sports
lane they got into the sports lane with
espn because they understand anybody in
the entertainment field
entertainment industry understands that
live sports is the most valuable asset
for attracting a massive audience and
being able to preach your values to a
massive audience
particularly in this now dvr
watch stuff when you want to
era that we're in live sports is the
only thing where people sit down and
watch it as it happens live and so they
wanted espn they wanted in the sports
world and they wanted to apply their
values their culture to the sports world
and that's what has happened and i think
disney
based on their attack on young kids and
the sexuality and the gender thing
disney believes in the matriarchy disney
believes in the uprooting of the
patriarchy disney is very feminist
and
uh they've applied all those values to
espn which is a worldwide leader in
sports and that's why if you just look
at sports over the last 25 30 years
since disney has owned espn
sports had just become softer and more
feminized i actually
i spoke about this in 2018
when we were seeing
culture you know uh video games movies
seeing all the woken flux
i said it's going to be real crazy when
the nfl the nba and major league sports
start being forced to adopt these things
and we're starting to see it you know we
spoke with uh jonathan isaac that dude's
awesome yeah and he was talking about
how he didn't want to kneel for black
lives matter people got mad at him about
it so we had a meeting we said we're
going to do this and he was like i don't
believe in it though the crazy thing is
here's a guy
you got colin kaepernick who kneels
he gets ragged on for it well he brought
politics into the game i understand why
people might be mad about that well the
politics there starts spreading to
everyone kneeling and now you got a guy
jonathan isaac being like i just don't
want to kneel i don't mind if you do and
they're mad at him because he won't bend
the knee
you see
i think i think
and just keep in mind everybody on espn
the worldwide leader in sports is
criticizing jonathan isaac and any and
lord behold take drew brees the
quarterback for the saints makes this
comment basically defending the national
anthem and he gets assassinated his
character does by everybody on espn like
he's some racist pig
because
the national anthem means something to
him means something to people in his
family that were in the service
and so that's these athletes are being
bullied into kneeling and adopting these
values we're actually uh this sunday we
got a special episode we we did a
podcast with ben and uh ben shapiro and
jonathan uh jonathan isaac uh separately
but um you know he was saying that he
doesn't think these people
believe in in the message that the
players are just kind of you know
they're told they have to do it and
they're like okay whatever i guess
and uh you know many of them probably
outright
just don't like these values i think the
reality is a lot of people are
christians i think a lot of people like
families
what worries me is why aren't there more
people like you know isaac who are gonna
just very calmly and passionately say
look i believe in my country uh no
disrespect to those who protest i'm
gonna do my thing why can't we at least
have more players like that i imagine
it's because the paychecks are so big
those guys they make so much money that
i mean how how can you turn away from 90
million dollar contract 10 million
dollar contract over three years or four
years or whatever they make what's an
average contract in the nba right now
probably five to eight million dollars
but but wait for like your average
player for how many years
you know what what about your rate of
five years what about your lowest tier
player like the modest tiers players
probably making 800 900 000
but but
let's take the big money people out of
it just talking to colin before the show
working in academia and i talked about
this today
about just corporate america in general
if you want to move up in leadership at
any major corporation if you don't adopt
the uh values of diversity inclusion and
equity if you don't hop on board with
all the lgbt stuff if if you don't
swallow it you can't move up
or you get run out of academia
yeah it's the same principles are
applied that you see the pressure in the
sports world is even more intense these
guys have guaranteed contracts and have
genera have made generational wealth
what if you're just the guy that works
at
name the company or disney or anywhere
that doesn't want to hop on board
with these values you get run out you
can't move up yeah it's the same same
dynamic that's taking place you know in
sports in academia i mean it's it's like
this spiral of silence they go into
where everyone else is doing this one
signal and if you have areas that tend
to be you know politically skewed in a
certain direction like academia as a
signal that might have started out with
like you know i'm just putting my pronun
in my email signature or in my social
media bio
these soon rather than just being a
signal of like oh i'm just inclusive it
then becomes the people who don't have
these little things in their bios and
their email signatures that becomes a
tell because once it gets so popular
then the person who doesn't do it is the
one that stands out and all of a sudden
people can question them and you know
what are you doing i'm interested in
your experience you're an evolutionary
biologist like with the with the i guess
you would call it the the emergence or
the the mainstreamism of the transgender
movement or i don't know what's called a
movement but just this whole like what's
it like in the science community when
you're discussing biology
you've got a story well no i just want
to
kind of pull back a little bit what
you're saying and merge these kind of
these conversations you know we're
talking about the feminization of sports
we've got someone you're a biologist
yeah well so let's let's talk about
what's happening with you know you can
define a woman he's a boss well exactly
exactly so
you know
i think we'll get to that in a second
but let's let's kind of merge that as a
biologist witnessing what's happening in
sports with the ncaa and all that stuff
what's what's your take and what what do
you have to say for you know what's
happening like what's your view on it
yeah i mean it's the same same dynamic
and it just requires people to feel like
they're comfortable enough by seeing
other people who are speaking up and not
getting canceled to to have them speak
up i mean when i was in academia there
was no one talking about the stuff i was
talking about i was one of the first
people to be like actually there are
only two sexes it's not a spectrum it's
not a social construct and i mean that
was all the arrows hit me at once and
that's a signal to everyone
to you know who thinks the same way i do
that they're not going to say anything
because they see what that's how it
happens when the one vocal person comes
up and so it's that chilling effect and
i think that's playing out in sports is
that chilling effect when someone gets
hammered in the media for their
reasonable opinion that just sends a
signal to everyone else like oh this is
a third rail i'm not gonna i'm not even
gonna go there
what what is this
right we all of a sudden we have
academia
terrified we have one of the most
lucrative and high-paying industries
major major sports and they are
terrified of this ideology
well because they know they can get
cancelled they know it's a tool yeah
that they can get run out of their jobs
and have to go independent the way that
colin has i do want to and i don't want
to speak for tim but i do think what tim
was asking you quite honestly was like
we had a man
leah thomas william thomas swimming
against women i was in the ivy oh you
were and yeah that's what he's like as a
biologist
what is your take this is crazy to us
well so it's completely yeah it's
it's completely insane i mean
so the the thing that's underpinning all
of it is this like this gender ideology
that is saying that
what a man or a woman or a boy and a
girl is has nothing to do with your
biology your your reproductive organs or
anything it has everything to do with
just your internal sense of of who you
are or your identification with social
roles and stereotypes of like
masculinity or femininity that's
literally what they think is is a man or
a woman which really goes against what
we've been hearing feminists say for so
long that you know a woman can behave
any way they want to and still be a
woman you can be a masculine woman you
can be a feminine woman you can be a
feminine man you can be a masculine man
but you're you're fundamentally defined
as a manner when by your your
reproductive anatomy
somehow this ideology has just taken
root i think a lot of it's because you
see these big organizations like the
aclu like the human rights campaign they
had all this fun all the all this
funding billions of dollars going into
something like getting gay marriage
passed which i personally think is a
good it was a good thing to get past but
once they get that big victory
what do they do next they're set up in a
situation where
they need to find something else to put
all this money into they have all these
donors they have they're not just going
to turn their lights off shutter the
windows and say like well we won time to
time to go home there's no more big
dragons to slay and if you look at where
the funding went in these organizations
it used to be all going into gay
marriage and then was it 2014 or 15 when
it became federally legal
yeah then you see the narrative switch
to trans everything and it's this gender
ideology and it's this built-in
apparatus with billions of dollars
behind it that is just shunting this
money into point five percent of the
population and
we have no response to it we haven't
built up
the organizations to respond to this
thing now that isn't the next i i used
to work
i used to work in uh nonprofits i did
fundraising
and this
was one of the things i witnessed a good
non-profit should put itself out of
business yeah if you say hey we got we
got an issue with uh there's not enough
panda bears
well you know maybe in 20 30 years all
of a sudden panda bears are no longer
endangered anymore what does the
non-profit do
waves goodbye to everybody and says
mission accomplished this was the goal
we saved their band
what what these organizations will do is
they'll say well it was never about the
pandas what about the kangaroo
what about this new songbird they don't
want to cease to exist they're they're
they
they they like the power they've accrued
they transition well and then they look
at people on their that they're paying
people they have paychecks they have a
you know they they have a video they
have
please i exactly i think greenpeace is a
good example of this i briefly worked
for greenpeace
and the one thing i didn't understand
and uh i started uh looking at um
i think uh what what's what's the lady
do you know the guy the greenpeace guy's
name doctor is it it's not i think it's
patrick moore right yeah we're gonna
have him i think yeah maybe yeah um i
know there's also a paul watson who left
and he's the the sea shepherds guy but
um i believe patrick moore's name can
you guys check
because he's pro-nuclear power oh yeah
and so he's been very vocal on similar
issues as us yeah patrick moore patrick
moore so greenpeace it starts because
they're opposing nuclear testing i
respect that i don't like the nuclear
bombs being tested and the devastating
effects it blanketed this planet with
radioactive particles that interferes
with scientific instruments so there's
yeah it's not good that everybody in the
planet was blowing things up to test
things and so they oppose it and they
would do things like send out boats into
the area so they couldn't conduct tests
and i'm like i dig it now they're saying
nuclear energy is bad why in my personal
opinion because nuclear is a scary word
it allows them to keep the the company
going and make money and there's reasons
why people like patrick moore leave
because they're like you're off mission
this is not what we're supposed to be
doing
these non-profits i agree i think it's a
really important point that often
doesn't get brought up
they they uh i remember
i was working for a nonprofit
fundraising and one of the one of the
organizations they were fundraising on
behalf of was the human rights campaign
the hrc
apparently and i could be getting this
wrong i was not high up or anything but
uh there was a conversation where there
are a few organizations that were
rejecting some bill because it granted
certain rights to
lgb people but not
t people
and so the human rights campaign was
like we're going to go for this because
it's a win these other organizations
were like no you know you shouldn't
so there was a point where they were
willing to outright be like we will
advocate for laws that do not protect
this group of people i wonder now if
it's just part of the the process that
once you get certain laws passed
now you can move on to your next mission
and make sure the money keeps flowing
you need more scare tactics i think i i
think you hit the nail on the head with
a large portion of what we're seeing
activism can't stop there's money to be
made this is why we're focusing on
microaggressions now we've ran out of
macro ones yep we skipped the dent
deci aggressions and we're going to be
moving on to
aggressions next i think we run out of
we we
have a very short supply of racism
and so now racism
is
oh you didn't call me by my proper name
i think we just had a baseball player
uh a baseball first base coach i think
just yesterday for the san francisco
giants
he got called a mf i can say
[ __ ] probably on this show
we do try to be family friendly but
we're not going to we're not going to
cry about
he got called an mf
and he said that when he when the guy
said it it reeked of racism what i
didn't know
literally
because there's such a short supply of
racism we've had to expand what is
racism and so now if in the heat of a
sports battle if you call someone an mf
and they happen to be black and you
happen to be white
that reeks of racism
i want to
if i can and i think i can do this on
this show not because i think you guys
are going to agree with me but i just
want to say it because colin said
something interesting and tim you push
me back in line if i'm taking the
conversation somewhere you don't want it
to go but tim said or colin said that uh
you agreed with same-sex marriage and
thought it was a good thing
i have to sit here and say i disagree
with that and and not because i have a
problem with the lgbt crowd the gay
crowd or whatever i think we've moved in
the society where we think everything is
for everybody
and i don't think everything is for
everybody
tim's genes they're not for me so i
should not try to squeeze into them
and
i don't think there was a long period in
my life where
i was very irresponsible
in my dating and sexual life and i was
never in the right mindset to be married
marriage wasn't for me i had no control
over and so i think we've moved to where
we just we want to make everything for
everybody and so i i i think my sexual
promiscuity
no different than
same-sex attraction it makes me not an
ideal candidate for marriage i i i agree
with the majority of the sentiment that
not everything is for everybody and
absolutely it seems like you know they
it's like the sarcastic ball in south
park where they make all the kids wear
the goofy things and the football
becomes a balloon when you try to make
everything equal then you know what do
you do you got to cut off the tall grass
however when i when i look at uh the
issue of gay marriage i agree with colin
i think it was it
this is an interesting conversation i
think it's good um i think it's good in
the sense that
lgbtqia plus people
should not be discriminated against
based on those characteristics
there's questions in what that means
when it manifests like who gets right
who gets access to specific spaces like
women's only spaces does that mean
female or otherwise i think that's part
of the conversation we have but i mean
like you can't throw someone out of your
business for specific reasons you know
like we want to be public accommodations
should be equal to all and we should we
should have this is my view it's the
more liberal view i suppose but i i
think that if you're part of society
you're paying taxes and we're all
funding this machine then
you should be able to accommodate
someone and not arbitrarily be like i
don't like the way you look so get out
but within certain uh within reason you
can still do that anyway you can give
someone no reason and say oh you said a
naughty word and so i have the right to
refuse service to anybody it becomes
increasingly impossible to actually
maintain control of people's views and
opinions but anyway just to the point of
uh gay marriage
the question i had
when prop 8 was happening you think it
was in california was isn't marriage
specifically an abrahamic institution
which is rooted in going to the church
and saying vows before god
if that's the case then i don't believe
it is appropriate for the state to
mandate what the church does however if
the state recognizes marriage as some
legal contract with legal ramifications
those must be granted to to to anybody
now there are certainly questions about
you know what the writers brought up
polygamy and things like that and i'm
like well there was polygamy a long time
ago it's not here now we're just talking
about cultural shifts and cultural
changes but if there are two people who
love each other
and this is the current standard we're
in i think you know lgbtqia plus they
should be able to get married and and
live together and they should have all
of the tax rights and legal rights i i
don't want to hear another story about
you know two men who love each other and
one guy gets sick and his his husband
isn't allowed to go in and see him as
he's dying that's a horrifying story
because i it's
a man and his brother you know his
brother gets cancer he can go in and see
him these two guys spend their whole
lives together they love each other look
i i don't think that's any of my
business
one one of the things that arises that's
changing everything
is going after kids
right
i'm not saying you know i think if
there's a teacher in a school who's gay
and a kid walks up and sees a picture
and says who's that the teacher could
say that's my husband and the kid can
say but you're but you're a boy how do
you have a husband the teacher should
then say well maybe you'll learn more
about this when you're older ask your
parents it's really that simple when
they start saying they want mandatory
education on very specific things where
some of these books have been
particularly graphic that's when i'm
like yo we are not talking about civil
rights for an individual we are not
talking about me saying i want to make
sure that the people i know and care
about are able to be there for their
loved ones we're talking about going to
kids and explaining in detail five to
nine year olds
serious adult things that it should not
be up to them it should be up to the
parents and sometimes there might be
parents who are like my six-year-old is
ready okay well i personally disagree i
think six is a bit too young you should
maybe wait till they're getting closer
to puberty but i'm not the parent so
there are still limitations to where we
as a society have to decide what is
abuse and what isn't
talking about marriage a little bit i
think you make a really good point
you've got to define what it is and what
it means i think that um in the church
it's a union of be under god essentially
and i'm not a hundred percent familiar
but it's really about like um like a
like almost like a magical union with
your soul but then when you talk about
marriage in the state it's just a
business contract and the way i look at
it in at this current state is it's i'm
treating like a business contract i want
to give my wife money my girlfriend and
i don't want to get taxed on it so i'm
going to marry her so i can give her a
bunch of money uh and and stop my love
for her is irrelevant it's a it's a it's
just a business deal um but i'm
interested uh how you guys and i hope
that i think that that's maybe the
conversation people in society should
have when discussing who should be able
to do what when it pertains to marriage
and what it actually means and then and
people sometimes you'll say like well
civil union then you get all the all the
all the digital rights without calling
it marriage but then they're like no i
want to label it the same i want to be
treated the same they start getting
identity politics
i think what jason was saying earlier
and what you were getting at was a sort
of slippery slope you get into
where like you have a movement like the
lgbt
q plus ia2 whatever and the reason that
number that those letters keep expanding
is because they've defined themselves by
we're the most inclusive
group ever we're gonna just accept
anyone who's
atypical what any any access you can
imagine
and
that leads to them not being able to
just really
push out the fringes of the people that
really shouldn't be part of their groups
you know like there are some
organizations that will want to add the
p which is the pedophile to like those
types of groups the peace is silent and
they can't police their borders because
they they've just we're so inclusive
it's an orientation and
by that like they need to be able to
police their border to some degree
because
some people are just bad people some
people in certain ideologies as well
have you guys you could mean police have
you guys
for sure have you guys talked about the
jeweler with the anti-woke ad
i don't know because i wasn't here for a
little bit we'll talk about that let's
pull this over we got the story from
timcast.com jeweler launches anti-woke
ad asking what is a woman
what is a woman
this is a this is a
what's fascinating i don't think the
story is inherently newsworthy
but it is interesting that people are
starting to push back and just begin to
assert
that women exist or that women are adult
human females
the reason i find this story interesting
enough to elaborate on is that it's a
jeweler doing it and why is a jeweler
making an anti-woke ad
well
jewelry there's a very traditional
gender
norm in the purchase and delivery
gifting of jewelry it is very often
typically a male will buy shiny rocks to
present to a female as they assign a in
an effort to woo said female then he's
like hold this for me because i don't
want to carry it around well i i do
think it's fascinating when you break it
down to its root it's like
you know we i'm gonna reference chicken
city when you watch when you watch the
rooster do the dance around the the hens
he like pulls out one wing and then
shuffles around him yeah he's trying to
tell the girl like look at me i'm hot
stuff
males in our society buy shiny rocks and
present those shiny rocks to women like
look at me look what i got you know i
can afford this for you
and it's courtship
if you get rid of gender roles you're
going to eliminate to a great degree
jewelry people are going to people are
doing tattoo rings instead they're
moving away from this so
i guess to break it down
what we're going to see is industry
dependent upon gender roles are going to
start becoming resistant and pushing
back because they want to exist much
like you mentioned in a previous segment
non-profits have to keep moving forward
with new groups to fight for
industries that rely like let's let's
talk about you know honeymoon escapes
where they're they have rooms designed
for a male and female specifically i
mean they're going to be like what do we
do in this new environment well i think
eventually you're going to see companies
just come out and be like no no we
oppose this because they don't want to
cease to function i will admit i think
everyone loves gems i don't know no
maybe it's just me but i i think maybe
it comes from that men hunted and if
they had a ring on their finger and they
got it caught on a branch it would rip
their finger off so they wanted as
little uh encumbrance as possible so
they would store the gems with the wife
i don't know if that's really the
history of why the woman had them and
the man didn't but then you look like
ancient kings and pharaohs and they were
all adorned with gems and jewels and
things like that so they may have a
market with both i mean the age of
hunting is essentially hunting for
necessity has has dipped not that it's
over but we seem to be in a law
they're going anti-woke that's that one
particular jeweler
i tend to agree with ian
because what's gonna happen these
businesses are going to adjust
to the new normal and so like this is
particularly acute
in the black community our culture is so
matriarchal
women are at the head of the black
community i i
somewhat reluctantly have to admit that
and so what jewelers are going to start
doing is they're going to create the
custom
of women
buying gold chains for their men
they're just going to adjust their
business model again it's no dif for me
i'm 54. i'm old my dad always drove a
cadillac i now watch sports events
and the cadillac commercials now all
feature black women mostly they used to
market it to black men that was cadillac
that was the joke that was the
stereotype black men drove cadillac's
cadillac has adjusted black women nile
drugs is it working is the marketing
working
i don't know i just know what i see
and
i'm in i'm just when you watch car
commercials and there are black people
in it
they're catering towards the black woman
primarily one thing a lot of people uh
notice is that commercials will have
mixed race families very often have you
noticed this oh yeah well of course
there are um you know more
what's the right word same race
marriages or well no no no i mean i mean
um yes but i mean the people who
complain about it tend to be more um
identitarian so they're like why are why
are so many commercials now pushing this
and i'm like oh slow down there buddy
they're not pushing it they're trying to
make money off everybody and my opinion
is that they'll end up making money off
nobody
right so so the point of the commercial
is they're tr you mentioned you know
black women with cadillacs
i i think it's fine if you want to
market to whoever you want to market to
right i was watching tv and an a a
dating a dating app commercial came on
featuring interracial gay couples and i
said you know look i have no issue with
interracial gay couples like by all
means have have your life live your life
i'm just curious as to how much money
they spent and how much money they think
they'll make off of a market that is
probably small i'm not saying they
shouldn't do it they can do what they
want but it's interesting that the left
position would be like it's good they're
doing this ad because of diversity
but are they advertising to a group of
people that don't actually want their
product or there just aren't that many
there's not that many people to buy the
product when you're trying to relate to
them
so in the instance of marketing
cadillacs to black women i'm wondering
if a culture exists
that has black women saying they want
this vehicle
so when they see a commercial they feel
represented by it or would they just be
like i don't want that car
well i wonder if they're seeing their
representation as you know you know an
interracial gay couple that might not be
who they're actually targeting they
might be who they're portraying in the
commercial but they might just be
targeting
the people who would just care about
that sort of identitarian thing
generally but i i understand however and
maybe it's just my assumption i would
imagine that you know a young white
woman might be like oh that's so nice
i'm gonna use bumble because
i mean look you're you're saying here's
a product for you and the you is someone
that is not part of that demographic
so if the commercial said
you know our app is for everyone male
female lgbtq it didn't say that it just
said find love and it showed you know an
interracial gay couple and so
i wonder if these companies will wokify
their marketing to the point where
they regular people will not feel
represented by it so in the point of the
the interracial couples in commercials
me personally well i don't care because
i i come from a family like that so i'm
kind of like yeah whatever but if you're
selling kellogg's they used to have
commercials where it'd be a black family
and they're giving this cereal to their
children or be a white family
now it's mixed and i wonder if white
families or black families see
themselves in those families or just
feel like that's not me i would think
psychologically if you have a successful
solvent company in your marketing you
would allocate 10 percent of your
marketing funds to off-market people
people that aren't part of your
demographic you probably do experimental
campaigns here and there but only if
you're already successful i can't
imagine a company that is just starting
up would try to market to people that
they didn't think they were going to try
and sell to
i had a question with you about gems
really quick colin uh yeah biology
biologically is there any evidence that
men or women are more drawn to shiny
objects
you know i i don't know specifically in
humans but there's there are a lot of
uh species a lot of you know insects as
well that do these like gift giving they
call them nuptial gifts and it's kind of
funny because sometimes they're shiny
sometimes there's like a built-in bit of
nutrition to it but you also see like
this cheating behavior where some
some male fly will try to give this gift
that looks like it's containing all this
nutrition but it's actually hollow it's
sort of like the cubic zirconia version
of like an animal trying to give you
know to to dupe this uh this female into
like mating with them by giving them a
hollow
hollow gift it's usually men giving the
gift to the woman it's almost
exclusively the male 1 it's usually
because they're seeking a mate to have
to have a child with yeah they woo them
over
so i imagine the gem industry is
probably similar to that then yeah i
want to add a point to tim still or or
the conversation in terms of
america what these companies think
they're doing and perhaps are doing it's
just like you talked about with the
democratic party and their immigration
policy they're playing a long game and
so
the the primary
uh values freedom
and individualism used to define america
that's what everybody wanted i want
freedom and i want to be individual do
what i want to do
they're trying to make
diversity and inclusion
the primary thing
and so they're appealing to people that
believe in inclusion and who define
their identity around how inclusive am i
oh i'm inclusive of trans folk trans
people i'm inclusive of everything and
so that's what they're marketing
it's almost like marketing patriotism
and like the nfl and sports have sold
themselves this is the most patriotic
thing you can do come to our game stand
for the national anthem blah blah blah
their inclusion now is like patriotism
and so these commercials are trying to
hit the theme of inclusion
because they think they have socially
engineered americans to believe there's
nothing more american than being
inclusive and tolerant and worshiping i
i wonder if there's a big ask element i
like inclusivity
i like diversity
i i don't like equity i think equity is
a lie in a manipulation but uh
inclusivity it's like you know if i'm
playing a game of dodgeball and i see a
kid who's out you know not hanging out
with anybody i'm the kind of person
who's like hey dude come over and hang
out with us or i'm at a skate park and i
see a kid who's by himself about you
want to come over and play game of skate
like we're all chilling and what's your
name try and include people and i like
building community i like diversity in
the truest sense i like diversity of
world view and opinion
and the original concept of diversity
was that someone who comes from a
different community will have a
different perspective than you not
always but sometimes and so you can
learn a lot from people that you don't
know don't don't assume
that other people can't teach you
something the problem with inclusivity
is too much of it is a bad thing in that
if you have i i was kind of an outsider
growing up and i thought you know if i
get popular i'm never going to let
someone be an outsider and i'm going to
bring everyone in and i tried that and
it became chaos and you know what also
is a chef i'm an amateur cook any chef
or whatever but if you add every
ingredient it's a mess you have to stop
you have to add specific ingredients you
use discretion when you're being
inclusive you have to you have and that
is a hard a hard thing for people to
accept because it does mean that people
get left out and that's that's a sad
thing but it may be stronger in the long
run
the issue now is that they've
these three words diversity inclusivity
equity have all just been perverted well
for one equity is garbage you know
equality i like equity is some kind of
you know equality of outcome instead of
opportunity but inclusivity was supposed
to be about compassion now it's about
homogenization and diversity was
supposed to be about different
worldviews and now it's just about
homogenization so you're not getting any
of these things in in in this woke
religion and too much inclusivity like
you were saying earlier you get the
fringes that come in and then end up
disrupting the very group you're trying
to build yeah and if you look at what
people mean when they say like we're
creating an inclusive environment just
to turn this on its head it basically
means the opposite in many contexts like
when i was first you know when i was
still in academia and i wrote a paper uh
for the wall street journal called the
dangerous denial of sex and it was about
my sex israel and why it matters i was
told that i was not making the
environment at penn state inclusive and
that therefore means
i needed to go
because i was making i wasn't making an
inclusive environment so i needed to be
excluded in order to make an environment
inclusive so it can be it can mean just
the opposite i want to do a semi hard
segue to this story from fox news
brooklyn subway shooting person of
interest frank james posted racist rants
to youtube for years i do believe he got
arrested and what i've heard and i think
you know i thought to jason to correct
me if i'm wrong is that this guy was
posting like black nationalist stuff yes
he's been
radicalized by corporate media we've
been sending
black people the message through
corporate media that
you're a victim you're oppressed
white people are the devil
uh and this guy bought what the media
was selling he's from milwaukee or
waukesha same area as the darrell brooks
guy who was radicalized
uh
this
it's no one should be surprised that
we're creating these types of monsters
uh because the media is basically tell
you're crazy if you don't think like
this guy i got a story for you jason
some people watch the show and have seen
it may have heard me but um i assume
most people haven't heard the story i i
know sometimes i tell stories you know
several times but there's different
guests so i apologize for it but i knew
a guy once and uh
i'll try and simplify the story for the
sake of their privacy there's a black
dude and there was a white dude and the
black dude mentioned he was gonna you
know
go run the store real quick
and the white dude said hey when you're
out can you mine you know when you're by
the store can you grab me a cheeseburger
from the you know the mcdonald's and the
guy said excuse me
and he was like
would you mind grabbing me a
cheeseburger when you're over there by
the mcdonald's and they start yelling at
him like what do you think who do you
think i am
later the you know i asked the guy like
whoa i saw you yelling like what
happened and he's like the dude he
thinks i'm his boy like i'm gonna go and
get him food and then i was like
i i if you were going to the store i
figured he'd just ask you to pick him up
a burger
and so that was to me i was kind of like
yo i was like i think you might be
looking too much into this and he said
you don't understand man you don't
understand what they think about people
like me
and then i was like when i was growing
up
it didn't matter what your race were
we'd be like oh hey you're out hey give
me a hot dog and fries would you do it
we'd be like sure
but i think what happens is you have
people constantly saying
you know it's like eber max kenny said
it's not a question of did racism happen
it's how did racism manifest you'll have
people who think it's everywhere and
look for it and i'm like
maybe maybe he just wanted you to be his
friend and you know do him a favor
maybe he wasn't being racist but if
people internalize that and they
constantly look for it they might get
offended where they shouldn't
this goes all the way back to the
feminization of america everything's
about feelings
women
are
driven by feelings more so than men
we've turned this entire society about
i feel like a woman even though i have a
penis i feel like
something was racist even though that
coach called
a white guy mfr and that's his language
of choice even though that same guy that
asked to get a cheeseburger asked his
white friend to get him a cheeseburger
the week before but if i feel like it
was racist
it is
and we all
seem to accept that standard i don't
personally though
growing up uh
you know i had friends who would use
racial slurs for all of us
and
he he wasn't racist
he was just it was just edgy young punk
humor we watched family guy in south
park so he'd go around and we'd all
laugh at it he would he would you know
call us names i'm like i don't care like
because he's my friend and i know he's
he's just trying to you know take take
jabs at me and it's funny and he would
call himself names too but today's day
and age it's like
you can't belittle these ideas
when i look back on what it was like
being a kid having a friend who would
call people names it felt like he was
taking the power away from it he would
say something that was ultimately
meaningless to all of us and was meant
in jest and kind of playfully so we
never got mad about it
nowadays they've empowered it so much
that even asking someone to grab you a
burger is like the epitome of racism
that it's everywhere always and it's not
the right it's the the woke who claim
they're they're anti-racist who are
funneling as much oxygen into those
fires of racism as possible yeah i
wonder is it biological like is it in
the diet in the plastics in the water
the micro
and the it's a big leap all these
chemicals like that are making people so
tense and edgy that they can't like not
get angry when they hear these things
i think a lot of it's just sort of
ideology going around it's it's making
people you know mentally ill in a way
that their social media man yeah it's a
lot of it's social media a lot of it's
clicks um a lot of people are staying at
home they just don't have their friend's
circle i mean this is the stuff like
jonathan height gregor lucky enough
wrote about and cuddling the american
mind um yeah we're seeing all all-time
highs of of sort of mental health issues
uh
depression um sexlessness among young
kids not young kid well
college aged people um i'd hope
sexlessness and young kids but uh yeah i
mean it's it's there's this skyrocketing
rates of mental health issues and this
is i think we're seeing sort of a
manifestation of a lot of that uh we
have this focus on these
these microaggressions so when i was in
in graduate school i remember hearing
from this
this other grad student was a black
woman and she was talking about how she
had this insane interaction that was
very racist she played ultimate frisbee
and we were like what was this incident
and she had just started playing
ultimate frisbee in this new league but
she was very athletic and so she did
really well on the first time that she
played ultimate frisbee and so some
friends after the game came up to her
they had never met her before and they
said man you're so good at ultimate
frisbee have you ever played before and
she's like no and then someone else said
well that's just good genes and she took
that as being an instance of
you know this microaggression because oh
i'm black i have these good genes and i
hear the story remember thinking no the
first instinct was have you ever played
before have you practiced is that why
you're so good and she said no
and then so well what's the other
alternative
you're just have a predisposition you're
athletic you're a natural you're a
natural nature person and so she
dismissed the nurture part the practice
because she had never practiced before
and then because the the next available
option was you're a natural
athlete that was racism and i just
remember thinking like this is
completely insane black people frank
james all we have been conditioned
to believe the highest level of our
existence is being a victim
and so we look that's how you prove
you're black i'm a victim
and so for that woman to prove her
blackness she's on a college campus i
would imagine she was a grad student
grad student on a college campus she's
lived a very privileged life there's
probably black people that tease her she
talks too good in english she's too
smart blah blah blah and so her way of
expressing her blacks
boy you wouldn't believe the racist [ __ ]
i went through oh someone at ultimate
frisbee said i was a natural
boom that's how she proves she's black
you know you wanna know what's crazy
i experienced racism in my life in fact
we had a guest on the show i don't want
to bring up his name let him keep his
keep his peace for the time being and
when i said i understand your your
worries about racism you know my family
dealt with some of this stuff he said no
you didn't you're lying you're a white
boy and i'm like okay so like if i agree
with you now i'm wrong i don't i don't
think i think a lot of it is just power
it is this fascistic ethos of there is
no truth but power this guy's clearly
not on my side he doesn't like what i
have to say so when i reach out and say
i understand that because i've
experienced similar it's denial and
rejection no you are wrong it couldn't
have happened to you and i'm like that's
just the weirdest thing to me you try to
relate to someone and say i can
understand your argument and they just
they basically spit in your face yeah if
i was like slap your mom i really like
your skin color man you have really nice
skin color like i don't hear that
compliment going around a lot but you
can compliment someone's bone structure
you got really nice cheekbones i was
told this today so i had to get makeup
for the daily wire oh boy they do this
thing where they're like uh they're very
polite about it they go uh would you
want to do any touching up any you know
makeup cause i got like a blemish in
there and i was like i'm good i think
it's fine like you sure just a little
bit i mean we can do it's a big deal and
i was like
if you guys think it's it's it's i need
it they're like no no no it's fine
we might as well right you know trying
to be polite about it but every camera
needs a nail but you know what you know
what the makeup artists always say
maybe it's just true for me they say you
have great skin no i imagine they say to
everybody because they're doing makeup
and they gotta say that to you and did i
go excuse me what does that mean are you
talking about the color
no i'm just like hey okay you know
whatever let me ask y'all a difficult
question this is a i think it because
it'd be difficult to be this transparent
but i'm this is the tim poole show you
guys are really transparent
as
in tim i know you're not white per se
but
do you have trepidation
in dealing with black people you don't
know
because you you anything you say can and
will be potentially used against you
does that thought cross your mind you
know coming in and talking to me it's
like you watch my show you know my
reputation oh i can be myself it's
whitlock but when you're dealing with
perhaps someone black that you don't
know do you
sit there and think like oh my god let
me be very careful no not after i see
their eyes the we are the brain eyeballs
spinal cord creature holding these
moving these
these saltwater bodies around you just
look in the eyes man it's not that we're
all the same i used to say that a lot
but it's like
i i don't even like the all the color
and the shape fades away when you're
communicating with someone and and they
everybody appreciates it that's been my
ethos since since i was like 14
at least since i was two you know really
when i was 26 you know what it is for me
it's politics not race
when you know
there's that study i think i was out of
yale we talk about quite a bit where
conservatives speak to black people
normally but liberals
like dumb down their language which is
the it's insane
i couldn't imagine doing that and so uh
you know for me
i'm like
i i really just kind of talk to
everybody the way i talk to everybody i
might have uh
i i think it's fair to say there are
certain assumptions we might make about
people based on race based on the
politics of the of our environment but i
would say 99.9 is just like
i'm gonna talk to this person the same
way i talked to everybody else because i
don't want to make assumptions about
them yeah first especially based on
we're not different races we're the same
species the homo sapien and i like
talking to people with different ethnic
ethnic backgrounds or like different
genetic backgrounds because our
ancestors lived in different
environments like the asian ancestry
maybe because the winds were so biting
in the mongolian plains they squinted
and over generations the babies were
just born so they didn't have to squint
you know or people with darker skin than
mine uh had a lot of sunlight people
with light skin like my ancestors lived
at night everybody has darker skin my
dad one time i was at the beach and my
dad was like we lost ian whizzy and they
looked on the beach they saw a glowing
white thing there he is
right here here's what i think is is
important to understand especially like
when it comes to race uh there's there's
different uh second like physical
characteristics uh say hair for instance
there's different hair products for for
white and black people or not
necessarily white and black but you know
there literally are different uh hair
treatments and styles so there's there's
an assumption someone might make but it
shouldn't change these things don't
change the way you treat a human being's
their their soul their their spirit i
wonder about this because you know when
we talk with people like sheamus of
freedom tunes for instance
and you know he very much believes in
the soul and the body as being one
i'm like is it is it something that
people who don't believe in a soul will
treat you like nothing but the body and
ignore your inner you know what i mean
you know what i don't like they'll look
at you and think your race is you
instead of wondering about who you are
as a person because you have a soul i
don't like when i talk to people about
people with dark skin if i'm talking
about the difference of light skin and
dark skin because it's relative to my
skin color and that's really rude of me
to act like that like i should be
talking about people with light skin
and and just see it from other
perspectives than me is like the zero
point as the starting point well let me
uh i don't know if you wanted to answer
that because i don't want to
no i mean i like to think i give people
you know the first volley in a
conversation and it is going to be the
same for just about everybody that i
interact with and you know over
iterations that's when i'll i'll build a
sort of a model but there's like hold on
i want to throw the question back at you
jason do you think you or do you think
black people have a certain way of
talking with white people in like a
similar fashion you asked us
in this culture today no i don't think
there's any trepidation any fear
uh because i think the culture has kind
of said
there are no standards for black
behavior
have you have you seen the ami horowitz
video on um voter id
i
think i have i didn't mean to interrupt
you so if you want to finish that
thought real quick no go ahead so uh you
know they say voter id is racist yeah
classic video i love bringing it up so
he goes to berkeley and he asks these
young white progressives is voter id
racist and what do they say of course he
says why he gets a few answers black
people can't afford ids black people
don't know where the dmv is and black
people don't have the internet so he
goes to the bronx he goes to harlem
and he asks this woman he's like ma'am
this might be he's a black woman he's
like this might seem strange but do you
have an id and she goes what
i know it might seem strange and she
goes of course i have an id he's like
okay he asks a young young black man
he's like
this i know i know might seem strange do
you know anybody who doesn't have the
internet and he's like what do you mean
12 year old kids know how to get the
annoy we got in on our phone but my
favorite interaction
is when he walks up to this like older
black dude and he goes
do you know where the dmv is he goes
yeah it's right over on 25th he turned
like he's giving him directions and i'm
just like for for the media to push this
narrative about black people it's like
have you ever talked to a black person
the assumption that they're a different
and foreign group of people to me is is
mind-boggling what i don't but it plays
right into that yale study i was just
talking yeah i don't like black and
white i don't like the words because
first of all my skin's not white it's
like pinkish your skin's not black it's
like brown red you know and like
historically white magic is like healing
magic and black magic is like dark arts
like
so like is the stigmas attached to
calling people black and white when
we're not
hold on i gotta i gotta push back
because that is a woke argument where
they're trying to claim that like harry
potter and magic the gathering are
racist
white and black as a reference to night
and day exactly it's not right in the
daytime you can see the predators coming
and at night you can't so there's this
inherent like scariness to the dark
knight you know so like i don't like
that people use black and white i don't
like black obviously
then stop playing magic the gathering
because black or white magic i'm a white
mage through and through that's just
gonna like to heal people i get where
you're coming from because the word
black bald
like black has the negative connotation
and which is arguing like jason's not
even black why are we calling him black
i'm not really white why i get that but
but because we've established these
cultural customs that we all somewhat
adhere to
uh you know we got to live in this
reality do we i want to shatter that
i agree i i think you're 100 right we
that should be the goal i think we
should be literally trying to live up to
dr king's dream judge people by the
content of the character the left seems
to be taking us the total opposite
direction and we now all have again what
you're seeing with black people
is that they interpret the world through
this lens of race every interaction and
it's like hey man some people just are
having a bad day it had nothing to do
with your skin color their wife
may have made them sleep on the couch
last night and so he's grumpy and gave
you a cold answer it it and so but we
escape anything that bad if if
if he punched me in the arm right now
i could oh he only did that because i'm
black that may be his way of greeting
everybody that he's
friendly with or finds you know
interesting or whatever
but we just describe
race and some negative connotation to
any experience we have we might we got
to go to school i got a really good one
though we are way behind so go quick
okay um it back in the day when we were
all like hunting with spears and stuff
if i went out there with my glowing
white light skin and i'm in the middle
of the night and the moon's out you're
gonna see me but if someone with darker
brown skin is gonna be more like
camouflaged maybe racism comes from that
well there's there's
or like fear
comes from that it comes from the other
the fear of the other but it's actually
harder to see darker objects at night
it's true but the the racism is rooted
in the idea of i know you're not from my
city i know you're not from my town i
know you're not from my tribe and that
first otherism creates fear and
tribalism but we gotta go super chat
sorry jason cause we are 10 minutes
behind tell me after the show
so uh let's go to super chats if you
guys haven't already smash that like
button i'm wondering if there's a lot of
super chats from when
the daily wire took over our broadcast
so that'll that'll be fun but uh we'll
we'll just see what you guys got
all right dr roller gator in the house
says hi colin this is gator you've been
in nashville for like three weeks how
are you still sober hashtag free dr
rollergator i mean i've been hitting up
some of the bars around town doing some
moonshining and distilling and all kinds
of stuff so we're going to i don't know
if i can say i'm sober you come into uh
redneck riviera
i've i heard about this saturday yeah i
think we're gonna be there from like two
to three but i'm not sure it might be
like 2 30 to 3. not as long as i thought
because everybody's very very busy and
then we actually have to get on the road
immediately
that's actually a big part of me coming
to nashville is because i googled
craft distilleries when i was downtown
visiting and like 50 popped up and i was
like okay i'll move here yeah sounds
good
right on all right let's uh
let's uh let's read some more super
chats
all right jason mcneil says hey tim
watch the vlog today with the troubles
of the camper would love to be your
full-time truck trailer driver there
were problems
comments
the comments on the vlog were like the
first 11 minutes were hard to watch i'm
a truck driver hire me well all i know
is i showed up in nashville and the
trailer was here because the crew took
care of business so i'm good i'm good
all right leor engelstein says
the latest quinnipiac poll finds joe
biden with a 26 approval rating among
hispanics lower than his rating among
whites almost like people like laws
yeah
i imagine a lot of people
who escaped communism
don't like the idea of socialism you
know the same
for sure
all right free men die free says you
still owe me tim cast irl episode with
ron paul luke said he can set it up one
of the most important figures alive to
have on your show
i would be honored
to have dr uh ron paul on the show uh
where is he based out of texas somewhere
but it's actually somewhere i don't know
somewhere i know it's the taxi in the
heart of texas i believe in the heart
that's my understanding i mean yeah we
should we should absolutely figure it
out and you know he's an older guy so we
should probably uh you know get on that
i'm a big fan of ron paul
and uh there's this um
yeah yeah just i'll just put it that way
i love the idea of liberty i've i've
always
i've never agreed with him on everything
because he does have more traditional
views but the idea of i will leave you
alone is very appealing to me so i'm
like you know ron paul i think it was
ron paul who said you can be a socialist
in america just buy land and make it
make your social soul commune yeah i'm
like yes yes please
that that that's what i always tell
people left libertarian is like i'm
gonna buy a farm me and my friends are
gonna live on it and we're gonna share
our our fruits and vegetables together
that's it you want to scale it up to a
big city good luck i don't think i don't
see that happening
all right medic knight says tim ask the
daily wire crew if they're familiar with
the libertarian party mises caucus if so
they should have dave smith on their
show to discuss debate ideas would love
to see dave versus ben shapiro that is
an amazing idea yeah that is and i think
uh i feel like ben would be absolutely
up for it and dave is amazing as well so
um if i uh
yeah i'll definitely i'll i'll
definitely ask about that because we're
big fans of dave and michael malus as
well i would love to see michael malus
talk with ben shapiro wouldn't that be
amazing have they never had a
interaction before i don't know maybe
maybe they did maybe they did so who is
your ultimate guest whistleless person
who
if you could interview one person oh i
don't know ron paul
um ron paul would be great i i i got joe
rogan
well i mean yeah that's a little
different
it's cool to have like the king of
podcasting on your show and he came in
and hung out with alex jones so that was
a pretty epic moment i don't know how
you topped that to be honest alex jones
and joe rogan came on this show at the
same time it's crazy who's yours jason
oh
man that's a great question i i should
have thought give me i'll answer after
you read the next one let me think about
that all right nick s says i hope you
got a high speed camera so we can play
back you and ben at speed the human ear
can pick up
someone you know uh just said turn the
speed down to 50 percent because uh we
we did a sit down with bench prior today
it'll be up on sunday in a in a bonus
sunday episode of it'll be like i think
it's like an hour and 15 20 minutes long
so uh just you know half speed
and you'll hear us talking like this
that's an interesting point then i sound
like sam harris yeah otherwise it's
gonna be like well but that's a really
interesting point which i understand
these kids in schools
we both talk very fast so
i mentioned that to one of the crew guys
and they were like oh yeah i know who i
want to interview there's two people for
different reasons barack obama because
i'd like to challenge him on the way he
handled the race issue
but probably the person i'm most
fascinated with right now is bill maher
because i think he's been completely
red-pilled
and is just
trying to ease his way up out of hbo
once he can get his podcast up and
rolling
uh and then he's gonna he's already
telling us what he thinks but i think
eventually he's gonna tell us what he
really thinks
you know
bill maher said in 2019 was it bring on
the recession because he hated trump so
much that all the pain and suffering we
see i i i just
someone tweeted about it and i said i'm
am i supposed to forgive that
yeah am i supposed to no i mean probably
no no i think he should be held to
account about it uh
but still forgive
and i think he should i think you know i
don't know if joe mentioned this to him
on the show recently but i mean it's the
first thing i'd say i'd say bill in in
in 2019 you said bring on the recession
and so many people are suffering
people are at risk of losing their lives
people i mean look in shang how bad it
is you know you wished this because you
didn't like trump and now things are
worse so it's like not only did you wish
pain and suffering on people because you
didn't like donald trump maybe you were
scared that i can get
but biden is worse
he's objectively worse so you wished for
pain and suffering and you got an
extended state of it
that's not okay let me add that's a
luxury belief let me add one point to
that because i wanted to say it earlier
when we talk about your conversation
with the daily wirecast about
presidential candidates this is why i'm
of the opinion that trump not running in
2024
might be a blessing because when trump's
not in office
it makes the democrats actually have to
defend their positions rather than just
saying trump you ask them any question
they just go trump and so once you take
that off the table that's why i think
you're seeing bill maher pivot so much
because he can't just holler trump like
he used to
so harry toe says no audio someone is
getting fired yeah what happened with
the audio was it uh i don't know the
technics do you so i know a little bit
about it but i think the daily wire was
sending us two channels that were
canceling each other out when you were
listening with headphones so if you
listen with headphones yeah because we
had people who are like it's fine for me
i can't hear a thing at all and
everybody's like okay refresh the page
or whatever so eddie unplugged one cable
and he made it all go away how long was
the audio out for i'm not sure there's a
few minutes there at the beginning nine
minutes like the first half or first
less than the first little bit less but
if you go back and re-watch the show
without headphones you may be able to
hear it yeah so now you know for sure
like that's that was the issue we had
two different i forget what they're
called i think they're called two
different channels i'm probably
explaining this wrong i'm not the only
but you guys in here heard everything
like normal yeah we did we heard
everything that's happened before it's a
weird thing i've seen happen before yeah
it was funky crazy how that happened but
it did bring a lot more attention you
know you know we'll have to do we'll
have to uh and and people so
benjamin said everyone go to the daily
wire live stream because oh yeah yeah
but you know what we'll have to do is
just if we if we if we have that glitch
on our recorded version for the podcast
we'll have to
just check for it i guess yeah we'll see
we'll see what's up there well you know
what guys someone someone said how long
was this planned for and i was like the
entire time we were planning on coming
out here well like a couple weeks before
i think
but when you get here and you're trying
to duct tape everything together to be
like how can we pull this off because we
need their feed to come to our trailer
we'd like run cables and do all this
stuff and these things happen it's truly
magical if you guys could see behind the
scenes of the production capacity that
went into it it was even with all the
awesome daily wiretech people it still
required a lot of thinking we practiced
it three or four times beforehand and it
was quite the production it's funny
because you see us hanging out all chill
but man there are people running around
pointing crazy
all right let's see we got
james just says can we fix the audio
well we did yes we can how long was i
was i up there for it's like my guess is
20 minutes wow 18 and the audio was down
for like maybe eight i could i was
worried about you guys i was like i'd
feel really bad if they keep me here
really long like it was fun we were
listening it was a really good
conversation it was a good conversation
it was great rv didn't miss you at all
no
rvdl says so is daley wire buying out
tim cast no
we are uh uh
timcast.com is a very large company
it's a uh it's relatively large
timcast.com has around what do we have
like 35 employees oh tim cast yeah
teamcast.com is the website well yeah
but tim cats in general we're a big
company i mean this trailer we're in is
probably like a 200 000 rig i'm always
telling tim man hold on to your ip bro
take it to the top but you know we've
got i think partnership's the key no no
investors
we've got no influence behind anything
we do i am i am but a single dude who
started making youtube videos and as
continually just every day i wake up i
put a brick down and i think it's
important however
there may be
certain deals because we're talking
about tv shows and i i don't know you
never know it really comes down to
it would be very difficult for literally
anyone to be able to buy out this
company at this point to be completely
honest but um what
what we are mostly talking about with
the guys over daily wire is you know
building culture we do not have the
capability to do move movies but we
certainly have a bunch of crazy ideas
for movies they want to do movies they
like crazy ideas and so i think that's
uh where we're headed we've got with
tales from the inverted world and a
bunch of other ideas certainly things
that might be of interest for them in
terms of making content so there might
be something you know going on we still
talk about it but i'm a big fan of the
daily wire crew i i heard you say
something the shoots very similar to
what jeremy believes you i think you
said it during this podcast or maybe
said it to me before the show
if you're going to change culture you
got to be willing to create it and
that's what i like what you're doing and
what the daily wire is doing but not
just that so
when we launched pop culture crisis on
youtube for everybody
go to youtube.com pop culture crisis
subscribe if you're into pop culture
content
so you know we had this conversation
very much at the beginning of the show
i'm like guys it's not about politics
the headlines should not be like woke
this woke that democrat republican with
you know cultural stuff in there it is
literally a story where it's like
disney launches new marvel show and the
reason is
too many people are just like let's
launch our new version of cultural
commentary where we make fun of what
they're doing and i'm like okay well i
mean that's great i don't care if you
know watch all of these cultural
commentary channels we do that what we
need is cultural participation
we need people who share our values to
be talking about the same thing
that regular people are talking about
not approaching them like an other and
complaining to their faces about it so
what happens is when disney announces a
new movie the guys over pop culture
crisis will be like here's the new movie
here's what's happening here's what they
think
behind that is their values so it's the
way i see it as
the what the mistake the woker making is
that they're making movies and putting
the message first
what the daily wire is doing is making
movies and putting the message secondary
so you've got good entertainment and
then it just so happens to have a little
bit here and there of like our values
are behind it that's what i'm talking
about pop culture crisis people can
watch about new movies celebrities video
games
and then secondary is well you guys know
we believe in freedom and personal
responsibility but we're not slapping
you over the head with it so we can
engage with the culture the next step is
making that culture but we're not making
hollywood movies so this is the this
this is the slow roll we're doing making
nashville movies now baby i mean yeah
hopefully hopefully
richard says i wouldn't be surprised if
youtube ruined the audio on purpose
talking about people who are furious
they can't groom kids what's cutting an
audio feed either way this is better
than the avengers
it was really fun because i said uh
i said that um
you know the title bench appear on the
daily wire crew takes over
people may have missed it but when i
walked in i straight up just said that
to everybody i was like yeah i just
titled it that ben shapiro was taking it
over because he's the most famous guy in
the room and everybody laughed and uh
but then i was like thank you all for
joining on my show
yeah that was fun but you guys heard all
that
we heard at the audience yes half the
audience heard it or something that
sucks maybe less maybe more than half
we'll get it right the next time we do
it because that was a whole lot of fun
we were lucky enough to be here while
they were doing backstage live like run
in and pin that mic on your chest that
was awesome you you're like watching me
run up and develop stuff yeah that's
great
that's so cool well you know what the
audio uh
oh man that means because i was talking
while i was going in there and that's
only on our end oh that was good yeah
yeah
all right adrian contreras as if crowder
shows up out of nowhere i will probably
have an accident
i i think
you know uh
we've got an event being planned in new
york now that they've lifted the
mandates and stuff
maybe
it might be too soon but i would love to
have you know an avengers moment just
get independent media people to come and
just you
what do we got to do to pack the madison
square garden
talk about it like five times on this
show it's gonna sell out so fast dude
that's 2800 seats no i'm talking about
the 60 000 seats oh
um yeah what do we got to do to make
that happen two months of publicity
i mean i you know i gotta be honest if
the daily wire tim cast crowder reuben
and maybe rogan you know he's not
necessarily in the same space but if
he's booked for chappelle if we could
i mean now get
reaching yeah i think dave would sell
him on his own yeah but i think if
everybody's promoting it we could do a
big event i think there's a big
like want for that stuff remember before
the pandemic they were having these
conversations between like sam harris
and jordan peterson they were selling
out fairly large venues i mean i think
they're that that really hasn't been
rebooted since then too like i think i
think there's still
potential for that for sure
kurt crystal says top 10 tim cast irl
moments
you know when they told me they wanted
to they were like how can we have you
jump
feeds to daily wireless like man we'll
need a remote camera it'll have to be
like here plugged in in advance we'll
need a way to switch it into our system
i was like that sounds tough especially
the last minute and the crew made it
happen yeah a lot of hard work great
teamwork between well i guess there was
an audio issue but you know yeah
incredible all right nanad sirejik says
what's up hassan stands in the chat glad
you decided to listen to an intelligent
conversation for once
you know i just i'll point this out
because we we this is also uh the
conversation that we all had with ben
shapiro which will be up on sunday as i
mentioned
why is it that it's always the right as
they as the left describes it that is
like our door is always open to all
people including the left to have a
conversation but it's always the left
saying no
they won't do it yeah
i had that recently scientific american
did a hit piece on one of my articles
saying that sex is real and i just made
i'm trying to be as polite as possible i
reached out to the editor you know just
saying like we should have a platform we
should have a conversation about this
and then now she's tweeting today about
how she's just getting trolled but
by me apparently so yeah
this this um middle-aged or i guess old
comedian woman gave an interview and
it's the weirdest interview because it
shouldn't exist because she's this
lady's not relevant she's she's not
relevant to the point where i'm not
going to say her name but she was like
whenever i speak up the joe rogan com
army comes for me the tim poole army
comes from me and i'm like what the
dimple army comes for you you're talking
about lady i never talk about you
you know i'm sure people know who i'm
talking about i'm not going to say her
name because i don't care about it
right but it's funny how they lie and
stuff
all right
ela says i love how independent media
supports each other you all talk about
the importance of decentralization and
it's awesome how you were all building
each other up instead of trying to knock
each other down walking the walk well
because i think one of the thing that
actually unifies
despite the differences in politics
between the daily wire us at tim cast or
stephen crowder is that
we agree to disagree we respect the
disagreement and we're we're we're
arguing and it's fun it's fun
but the left is like i'm not going to
come on your show and talk to you they
just want to hide behind their screens
and
you know engage in sophistry well it's
rare that i disagree with someone 100 so
even when you're talking about you know
your christian perspective and i'm you
know card-carrying atheist there's still
things there's truth to what you're
saying
about you know gay marriage and things
like that and you know slippery slope
stuff so it's to me it's just like
finding those areas like where
what is the truth and what you're saying
where can we
what can we work with how do we override
i think the common humanity really that
are searching for truth
and there are people
promoting an agenda and if you're
searching for truth you'll talk to
anybody because who knows that person
may have some piece of truth that you
not aware of if you're promoting an
agenda
you know you're going to stay away from
certain people scott knowlton says timmy
should relocate to nashville make
nashville the conservative hollywood
i think one of the big things
conservatives have going for it is that
post liberals are basically
conservatives now like look at this guy
ian can we get in look at him look at
everyone i think of myself as neutral
can i be neutral just like centralized
and neutral but think about what you
were saying about how you didn't like
white and black be you know magic
because it's like negative reference i
mean that's a pretty liberal statement
but but when we have conversations
you can you can disagree on certain
ideas
but what we do agree on for the most
part between the daily wire and us is
is a story true or false were the
covington kids being racist no they
weren't but the left thinks they were
and that's what makes them left there's
times for every human to be liberal and
there's times for everybody to be
conservative and then if you start
labeling yourself i'm a big c this thing
just that's identity politics don't
don't worry so much about that boxes you
in
boxes you in from the truth
away from the truth
yep
the the distinction between left and
right is
truth and fiction the left keeps falling
for every hoax the right challenges
these stories and then turns out to be
right most of the time so i think when
people say we should move to nashville
to make a conservative hollywood i'm
like i mean look conservatives don't
think we're conservative you take a look
at me walking into the daily wire hq and
i even mentioned i'm like look how i'm
dressed compared to everybody else here
i think you know we might have come from
different worlds a little bit i'm
wearing sneakers jeans and a t-shirt and
they're they're they're all dressed very
well
you know i go in there especially
michael knowles oh absolutely
and and i you know they're they're not
uh uptight people they just dress you
know uh for business
well they're suits right
and so my i'm like
their suits war street
were you know but if we can agree on the
basic facts the conversation can exist
we can disagree on certain things but we
agree on what reality is so if we came
to nashville the big advantage that uh
that the right has right now
conservatives have is there are many
people like me i know a lot of pro
skateboarders who they message me
periodically they're like love your show
we're big fans we agree
because we don't like what's happening
with the authoritarian cancer culture
people do not want to live in fear that
someone's going to try and destroy their
life let's move to nashville
let's get a studio like an hour out of
town where you just put this big
investment into the freak stand and
nashville is ridiculously expensive like
an hour out of that's kind of far 40
minutes out of town we're nine and a
half hours away i i love that we got it
dude nashville the birds chirp all night
in nashville
what is up the music city i don't know
there's something in the air and there's
electricity in this area everybody's
singing man all right yoda thrash says
whenever jason is on it's total worlds
collide for me it's the old school bmxer
guy who wants to talk street spots with
tim but then football guy that wants to
talk to jason about zone coverage versus
man-to-man
[Laughter]
is there a time and a place for zone and
man or do you pick one or the other ah
there's a time and a place for both
all right let's grab some more
let's see we got we got so many we got
so many brian beatty says twitter just
suspended libs of tick tock is that true
that is true oh wow yes that is
holy cow that is big i am offended
i am offended twitter for what where's
elon musk he hasn't tweeted in days yeah
well there was that thing that twitter
had like the the new policy they put in
i think it was maybe even a year ago
where it's just like if they're posting
people in like public spaces and
everyone always said this could be
something that they might use to then
just be able to remove accounts for
violating
sort of these types of things this could
be
that coming to coming to roost i so we
got some super jets i think there was a
sound cancellation thing happening yeah
that's what i'm talking about it's
happened to me before yeah uh so i i
once did a skype with somebody and for
some reason we could get the audio to
work and then i can't remember exactly
what the issue was but it was something
like this orange red says the sound
worked with headphones my audio worked
the entire time missed nothing i'm
wondering what that was all about that
some people weren't getting it some
people were it was a cancellation so it
was like i want to say two different
channels that are operating at the exact
opposite frequencies yeah which cancels
out noise if you're listening with
headphones not if you're listening well
he was orange red says they were
listening with headphones interesting i
don't know something like this happened
to me before it's weird hey i wanted to
say too that um libs of tick tock was
suspended by twitter over quote hateful
conduct so i'm really curious if elon
musk has anything to say that is so
vague it is vague so darn big
all right let's see we'll we'll just
grab a couple more here fami whammy says
love your show please limit ian's weed
intake beforehand never believe it or
not ian does not smoke weed uh i've
never seen him smoke weed no no i would
like you to see me smoke weed someday
though
someone mentioned that joe took down the
bill maher episode is that true that's
not true i don't know
i guess we could check that site
all right let's grab uh let's just grab
one more here we go sparrow rose says
tonight is extra special to me love
jason and colin and then someone says we
need an audio person you know
yeah we have so many audio people
working on that
i i know i think we've got an amazing
rig everything was tested three times
and we have the entire daily wire
production crew making this happen and
then these things happen isn't that
crazy i was worried about it i was like
something's gonna go wrong in it yeah
space travel is amazing that they can do
that they can send a space spacecraft to
mars and everyone lives well the moon
all things considered it went well yeah
yeah well i think you know it's weird
that a lot most people a lot of people
are saying it was fine and some people
were saying it wasn't but uh we'll we'll
get it sorted for the uh the podcast
version yeah we'll figure it out and for
the segments too we'll get it fixed but
uh everybody if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
today was awesome we're gonna have a
special members only show coming up at
11 p.m eastern so that will be up at
timcast.com for members only because as
members i want you all to think i want
you to realize something
cnn plus reportedly only has 10 000
daily users that means we are bigger
than them that means when you are a
member of timcast.com you are part of an
elite group of people that is better
than cnn i know i know you don't need to
be a member to be better than cnn it's
not hard to do but at least you can be a
card-carrying member that is better than
cnn so uh no i gotta say in all
seriousness
i am so uh uh grateful honored that you
would be member members of timcast.com
to the point where i can tweet
timcast.com is bigger than cnn plus
because it's kind of just like
i despise the corporate press the
manipulation so much
to know that there is something bubbling
up that just believes in honesty and
to the best of our abilities
it makes me feel good so everybody
thanks so much for all your support
smash the like button you can follow us
at tim cast irl you can follow me at tim
cast jason do you want to shout anything
out i do i got to go to the bathroom
my phone went dead
i'm 54 years old i haven't peed in five
hours yes uh
give it to me it's time for me to pee
but thank you so much for having me
oh and please check me out at fearless
uh fearless with jason whitlock at blaze
tv and everywhere podcasts are awesome
right on man thanks for coming we
appreciate it colin you want to show
anything up yeah you can follow me on
twitter at swipe right that's
w-r-i-g-h-t and check out my
website realities last stand.com for
good commentary on sex and gender right
guys ian crossland here love you guys
love you guys thank you so much for
coming that was great hopefully do it
again soon yeah sooner or later whatever
do it again anytime you're in nashville
hit me up yeah baby thank you guys all
for tuning in on this super fun night
and for bearing with our sound issues i
will try to fix those i'm sure we'll
have no issue with it you guys may
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlist as well as
sourpatchlids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in just about an hour thanks for hanging
out bye guys
you